in this video we'll talk about
eukaryotic transcription
we would look at the nitty-gritty
details in this video so stay tuned till
the end transcription is the process of
copying a segment of DNA and making a
RNA out of it so the RNA is the
blueprint for making protein or
sometimes also making RNA and this
process is known as transcription
eukaryotic transcription is much more
complicated than prokaryote this
particular transcript is produced many
number so DNA is read several time by
the reader which is the RNA polymerase
and several copies of mRNA is generated
in this video we would talk about the
steps of eukaryotic transcription that
means initiation elongation and
termination
we would look at the factors that
regulate eukaryotic transcription such
as transcription factors activators
repressors and many others
then we would talk about the
chromatin-centric view of eukaryotic
transcription and lastly we would look
at the techniques to study transcription
in Vivo
so let's start with the conventional way
of looking at this transcription process
everything starts at an initiation step
and everything starts at the core
promoter so RNA polymerase 2 has core
promoter element and the most
characterized core promoter element is
that Tata box
which has several thymine and adenine
nucleotides in sequence
so the Tata box is bound by
a transcription factor which is a
general transcription factor of TF2
family
this is known as tf2d this has two
domains one is tbp the data box binding
protein it binds to the DNA and distorts
the DNA eventually and there is a
tbp Associated factor which interacts
with other components
one of the peculiar features about TF2
in the DNA and bends the DNA almost
around 90 degrees
so after tf2d there are other factors
which would be recruited but TF to D
unlike other transcription Factor don't
have Alpha helical structure in the DNA
binding domain instead it has a beta
pleated sheet and all these kind of
structural information was derived by
extra crystallography the basic
understanding of mechanism of
transcription come from these x-ray
crystallographic data
now
there are other components such as tf2b
tf2d and tf2a which are associated in
this particular core promoter region
tf2b is an important player in this
process eventually tf2f would be
recruited which brings in the RNA
polymerase as well and in this complex
TF2 e and tf2h are associated now this
particular complex is known as the
pre-initiation complex still
the RNA polymerase cannot move out but
still the minimum requirement is kind of
fulfilled
when can RNA polymerase move out when
tf2h which has a kinase activity
phosphorylate specific serine residues
in the c-terminal domain of the RNA Paul
2 that is the signal for RNA polymerase
to move out of the start side and run
along the gene body this is the signal
for RNA polymerase to begin the
transcription and thereby the initiation
process is completed
so let us quickly summarize what we
learned in terms of initiation lot of
factors are associated the key factor is
tf2d and data box binding protein is a
subunit of tf2d
then other factors such as tf2b and tf2a
get recruited further it has been shown
that tf2b
interacts with other core promoter
elements such as bre element
then there is RNA poly2 recruitment
along with tf2f
it's important to note that the tbp tf2b
and DNA complex is stabilized by tf2f
which is really important for
transcription initiation later on tf2h
is the biggest subunit of all these
General transcription factor and it has
phosphoryl it has the kinase activity so
it can phosphorylate the C terminal
domain of the pole two which is a start
signal for the RNA polymerase to leave
the promoter region and run along the
gene body and thereby transcription is
initiated
now after transcription is initiated the
polymerase gets told in a position just
nearby the promoter
and this is known as proximally paused
polymerase and this is a problem for the
transcription process so at the first
goal
polymerase cannot run the entire Gene
length and it requires additional help
from factors
why it cannot run the full length there
are factors such as DSF such as negative
elongation factor which are holding the
RNA polymerase movement
now there are
elongation factors such as ptfb or
positive transcription elongation factor
which phosphorylates the nef the DSF and
the C terminal tail phosphorylated Naf
or negative elongation factor
dissociates from the RNA polymerase and
this is a signal for RNA polymerase to
move further and get released from the
stalled position now RNA polymerase is
free to move and it moves along the gene
body transcribing the RNA you can see
the RNA is protruding out right now so
this is the overall
elongation State during the time of
elongation few important biological
modifications are happening in the RNA
first of all there would be recruitment
of several enzymes collectively known as
the capping enzyme because eukaryotic
mRNA has a M7 G cap on the 5 Prime so
there are enzymes like methyl
transferases guanal transferase and
triphosphatase which work hand in hand
to
bring this kind of modification in the
five Prime end of the nascent mRNA
before even
elongation can finish and the
transcription process is terminated the
M7 G cap is formulated
now why M7 G cap is important because M7
G cap protects against nucleus attack it
can help in mRNA export and also it can
interact with translation initiation
Factor so it can Aid in Translation as
well
just like these uh capping enzymes there
could be other category of enzymes known
as spliceosome so this splicing enzyme
ensures that the introns are spliced out
and only exons are left out so that is
already happening when the elongation is
in progress
so all these splicing enzymes are
recruited into the c-terminal domain of
the RNA polymerase and they do their job
in the termination step
there are few important events which has
to happen
a poly adenylation tail has to be added
there are specific signal sequence such
as double A U Triple A these sequence
attract the protein cpcf or
cleavage promoting Factor there is also
cstf cleavage stimulating Factor
ultimately there would be recruitment of
polymerase known as polyadenylation
polymerase which is template independent
and as a result RNA polymerase would
eventually be dissociated and a poly a
tail would be generated if you need to
learn more about the poly adenylation
process or the M7 G cap formation
process you can click on the video in
the I button or in the description for a
greater detailed video anyway let me
talk to you about some Landmark
discoveries in context of eukaryotic
transcription Roger konberg who was
actually a family member of Arthur
conberg got the Nobel Prize in 2006 for
his key contribution in the field of
transcription
two of his major contribution was to
solve the 2.5 Armstrong resolution
structure of the RNA polymerase and
later on in recent year with the help of
cryoelectron microscopy they figure out
the structure of entire RNA poly2
pre-initiation complex these are two
Landmark papers in the field which has
changed our understanding about
eukaryotic
provided in the description so don't
forget to take a look at those
anyway
so far we are talking about the
transcription happening in a test tube
things are much more simpler in test
tube but things are difficult when thing
when these processes are happening
inside a in that cell let me tell you
why
because
the gtfs or general transcription
factors such as that TF2 family
transcription factors at the
minimal requirement for transcription in
a test tube
but it really does enhance the
transcription rate that much in
eukaryotes in the in Vivo situation the
rates are very different compared to in
vitro so what really regulates the
overall rate
it turns out there are regulatory
elements
that can influence the transcription or
rate of transcription
so this is the core promoter where the
general transcription factors are
recruited and which further recruits are
in Nepal too so this is the minimal
requirement for a transcription to begin
alongside these General transcription
Factor there are specialized
transcription factor which can be
recruited into the enhancer they can
interact with other components such as
mediators which can be either let's say
repressor or activatory complex and
based on these kind of interplay
the fate of a gene is decided whether it
would be transcribed or repressed
let me tell you about this in bit more
details so let's say a particular region
is linearly far away from a particular
Gene promoter let us say 30 kilobase per
far but these distantly look located
regions can come closer if a loop is
formed so generally enhancer promoter
Loop is formed where RNA polymerase can
be recruited specialized transcription
factors can be recruited into the
enhancer region and it can bring out the
transcription in a much stronger fashion
so there are specific methods known as
3D conformation capture which can
capture the 3D conformation of a
chromatin and can tell us that which
locations in the genome are coming close
in 3D space and time so these kind of
method can really tell us about a
contact map in a different video we'll
talk about high C in much more details
but let me tell you that okay if this is
a 3D chromat chromatin the chromatin is
really Dynamic at time t 0 let's say a
point A and B are close together but at
time T1 they might be far apart think
about again the time t 0 there there
might be two points
C and D which are far apart now at time
t one they have come closer so all these
contacts are new contacts are built and
old contacts are resolved so that is why
3D chromatin is highly highly Dynamic
it's not only within the chromatin there
could be interchromatin interactions as
well
one enhancer region might be present in
completely different chromosome which is
influencing another particular chromatin
so that is completely possible that's
why we have to understand the
transcription from a 3D or a
chromatin-centric perspective so let's
begin the understanding of chromatic
concentric view of eukaryotic
transcription there are many players
don't get confused things are a bit easy
so this is a 3D cell we zoom into the
nucleus because the nucleus is the hub
for transcription inside the nucleus
there would be genetic material densely
packed like this
so in this densely packed Forest of
nuclear Forest of like DNA
transcription Factor has to find its
promoter or enhancer region so things
are very very complicated jam-packed
inside the nucleus so how this problem
is solved so whenever we look at the
particular nucleus we cannot think only
about the DNA because DNA is wrapped
around histonectomers forming chromatin
that is why we need a chromatin-centric
view let's say at a promoter General
transcription Factor are added and then
polymerase sits on the promoter and
tries to start the transcription but in
the path of the gene body there are
several obstructions such as nucleosomes
which can act like a roadblock so how
these roadblocks are overcome that is a
key essence of understanding the
chromatin-centric view of transcription
it is also possible that the chromatin
is wrapped around the histones so
tightly that RNA polymerase or the
transcription factors are not getting
enough access to the prom promoter
so how does transcription happen in that
case how is the accessibility achieved
so let me tell you transcription factors
are not lonely beings they always
interact with other molecular players
such as the nucleosome remodeling
complex as the name suggests they
remodel the nucleosome sometimes they'll
loosen up the DNA wrapping around the
histones and creates accessible areas
for transcription factor to bind it also
create accessible areas for RNA
polymerase this is only one way
there are many other ways
so imagine in a 3D chromatin there is
transcription factor which cannot gain
access so it take help from the
nucleosome remodeling complex which now
also uh can change the chromatin
accessibility also that specialized
transcription Factor can interact with
let's say the histone acetyl
transferases which can modify the
histones in these nucleosomes let's say
they deposited some acetyl group so
overall packing of the nucleosome is now
going to be changed
acetylation of the histone would create
more accessibility the chromatin around
this region would be Loosely packed
that would allow the transcription
Machinery to be recruited into the
promoter and the RNA pole can start its
job can run along the length of the gene
body so this is one of the key essence
of regulation of eukaryotic
transcription so model of the story
transcription factor and its function is
depend on what it interacts with what
are the friends of these transcription
Factor transcription Factor can interact
with co-activated complex which lead to
activation of transcription it can
interact with co-repressant complex
which might lead to a inhibition of
transcription it can interact with
histone acetyl transferase which can
lead to increased accessibility of the
chromatin which would in in turn
increase the probability of
transcription
then it can interact with histone de
acetylase which compacts the chromatin
it can interact with nucleosome
remodeling complex which can do plethora
of things either replace some histone
either totally kick out histone from its
own location and maybe slide nucleosome
and free up new DNA regions
so lot of possibilities are happening
happening inside the nucleus a
combination of these steps might happen
not all of them are necessary together
anyway there are specific variant sense
of
particular histones which are associated
with transcription such as H 3.3 is a
histone variant which is associated with
actively transcribed genes this
particular histone can be found in
promoters Gene bodies and CIS regulatory
elements H 3.3 chip seek would be a
ideal way to understand where these
particular alternated histones are
located in a gene body or let's say
in a regulatory element similarly h2se
is another variant of h2a histone and it
is selectively found near the
transcription start site
so there are specific histones which can
dictate the type of the overall
rate of transcription so question is how
how can these histone variants modulate
the transcription if you don't know
about chipseek there is a video in a
link in the description box you can
quickly look at what is chipseek but
chip stick tells you that okay what all
uh particular histones or specialized
proteins are located in which region of
the chromatin
anyway so let's say
uh how do we know a particular Gene is
actively transcribed we can also look at
the serine 5-phosphate chipseek you know
all the
polymerase which are active they have to
be phosphorylated in the serine
5-phosphate region so any Peak
corresponding to Serene 5-phosphate
would show us or tell us that the
transcription is active so in this case
the pink Peaks all over the gene body is
showing us that the transcription is
actually active
okay but what is the mechanism what is
so special if H 3.3 or h2se is recruited
it would augment the transcription it
turns out that h2a Z and H 3.3 when
recruited destabilize the histone
histone and DNA histone interaction that
means chromatin conformation now changes
it opens up and helps the transcription
factor to be recruited and specifically
Bound in a region so it increases
accessibility by destabilizing the
nucleosome so take home message histone
variants alter the interaction between
his stones and his tone DNA
so that is why
next thing that one should ask like who
is putting these particular histone
variants in place it could be nucleosome
remodeling factors or histone chaperones
it turns out that these H 3.3 version of
his particular histones are recruited by
his Stone chaperones whereas h2az is
recruited by specific remodeler
complexes such as P400 or Sr caps
so all of them are like uh swr1 type of
nucleosome remodelers
we have
understood why
studying chromatin point of view is
really important to understand
transcription
now let us be a little bit more
scientific and try to ask ourselves how
we can explain
understand transcription is happening or
not okay transcription is fairly simple
process so if transcription happens
there would be production of RNA so
quantification of RNA would give us an
Essence that how much transcription is
happening
one can look at processes like real-time
quantitative PCR to quantify specific
mRNA of interest you can do like tens
and let's say several order of uh 10
mRNA to look at whether some specific
genes are getting expressed or not so if
you want to look at selective genes
real-time quantity of PCR is good
but what about if you want to get a
holistic view or let's say a global view
then RNA sequencing is a good technique
so it tells you how Gene a to Gene Z
means like
there are so many genes that can
possibly change and RNA sequence give
you our overall Global picture about
that
okay so now there are other strategies
such as reporter assay or let's say
spatial information can be obtained by
fluorescence uh in situ hybridization in
reporter I say you start with a reporter
Gene so reporter Gene fluorescence would
tell you whether a transcription is on
or off so if you have fluorescence
transcription is on if it is not on then
the fluorescence would be low or that
would give you a readout that the
transcription is off
so more or less transcription would be
indicated or read out by the level of
fluorescence so these are linear readers
and can be tracked in a live cell
then spatial information about
transcription can be obtained by
fluorescensely labeled probed so
basically using fluorescent level probe
a particular mRNA can be detected in an
in a Vivo situation in an intact tissue
this is known as intact tissue or cell
this is known as fluorescence in situ
hybridization so it can also tell us
okay not only transcription is happening
or not where does the new mRNA are
located so all these informations can
also be obtained by this particular
technique
now chipset is another very useful
technique for molecular biologists to
understand the aspect of Chromatin
because we need to understand the
transcription from a chromatics in
chromatin-centric view
so
signatures like h3k27 acetylation
H 3.3 h2se serine 5-phosphate combined
with RNA Peaks can tell us what is the
level of transcription in this case you
see H 3.327 acetylation is a global
acetylation or a gene activatory Mark
and this case it is totally lying
throughout the gene body that means
that means this particular gene or the
chromatin correspond to this particular
Gene is very accessible also H 3.3 Peak
tells us the same story H 3.3 is found
in actively transcribed genes h2az
combining with Serene 5-phosphate chip
seek and RNA Peak is telling us that
this particular Gene is actively
transcribed in this given time point so
Chip seek is a good way of understanding
various aspects of transcription
now let us take us take some example of
a multi-ohmic approach so let us have
two cell types neurons and fibroblast
and let's see whether a gene of Interest
Gene a is expressed in one cell versus
other cell
so it turns out that Gene a is expressed
in the neuron that means mRNA of Gene a
is found in neuron and not found in
fibroblasts so it's kind of like a
neuron specific Gene
so only by looking at the RNA we get
partial picture
we need to look at
ataxic Peaks ataxic is a technique which
tells us how accessible the chromating
is so in order for transcription to
happen chromatin need to be accessible
one can look at the chip seek Peak for a
particular histone Mark or let's say a
transcription Factor binding then
combine these information with RNA
sequencing to get a holistic view about
the transcription of a particular Gene
in a particular cell type or a
particular context that means multiple
High throughput sequencing approaches
need to be combined together
to derive a conclusion now if this video
is too quick for you then you can click
on the I button and go to the a toxic
video and try to understand how it
actually works but anyway we learned
several ways by which we can study
transcription you can get more nodes and
flashcards in my Facebook page or my in
my YouTube Community post you can
support our channel to get this kind of
high quality videos all the time you can
tell your friends to support us as well
see you in next video